i just remembered something all right um
okay i get rid of
gears of war no that was a good pick
that's a good pick
no no no subnautica in there i'll get
rid of subnautica yeah
um i just remembered something uh put
fifa09 in terms of end the podcast
what the [ __ ] i just [ __ ] remembered
i was [ __ ]
i got i was i had a period in my life
where i was obsessed with fifa
all right i i am i am not joking i'm
also smoking cigarettes on a corner
okay this is this is during the
university you know you're in a british
university
everyone played refuse to be like no no
i'm gonna play anything else
[ __ ] this game i just remembered
something
i i i was one of the top 200 players of
fifa
at a point yeah yeah yeah i'm not joking
i'm not joking
there's like oh this is like just giving
me flashbacks this is like connor coming
out but it used to be like a confront
it's like god used to be a female oh
nine so how are you how are you the top
200 how did it work is it like rankings
yeah it's it's like ranking it's it's
it's a literal ranking system and
i it got to the point where i was just i
just got myself on the leaderboards
of of fifa that's how i did it
because i was just obsessed with the
game and like everyone started playing
it so i'm just like
oh i guess i'll play fifa did you
demolish everyone
in like your unidorm yeah pretty much
because
because here's the thing because uh like
my my group of mates
and my unidorm uh they were like super
super competitive over fifa right
it was they were like that in mind and
this is how you get bragging rights
there was two games it was cod and fifa
and
i was just to me it was just like fifa
was not like watching football at all
fifa was just like
the ball goes and um
and yeah i don't know i just got really
good at it and i don't know how because
um yeah i mean just the british in you
yes well yeah there was two games
because i [ __ ] i i
i i feel like it was one game where i
got good at really unintentionally and
it was probably the only game i've ever
played in my life that i got good at
unintentionally
and i don't really like football that
much what's wrong with you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you top 200
in the world
i hate this game literally i just need a
worthy opponent
the the fact is like i had completely
blanked that from my memory until it was
like
just now yeah full time we don't know
i'm just like how the [ __ ] did that
happen how the [ __ ] would i get top 200
in
in the um yeah i top 200 in fifa and i'm
just like
yeah i just played it and i just kept
ranking up and then i just got really
bored and i stopped playing because
and the reason i stopped playing was
because i finished uni
and uh i didn't have a reason to play it
anymore
wow no because i remember now how it
started because i got the game literally
just to blend in with the normies so i i
literally got the game so
i could have something to talk to people
about at parties right
and so i'm one of them he literally
bought fifa as a social gimmick
yeah yeah yeah so i started playing it
so i could like keep up my mates and
everything
and then i just kind of figured out a
meta
i guess because you know it's football
everyone wants to score goals and then i
quickly realized
if you just learned how to defend
correctly and if you just
could defend goods you are better than
of players that ever played that game
because everyone only wants to score
goals and then so
after that so i've so after that then i
figured out the broken teams and the
broken team was barcelona
because they were the best team in the
world at the time but then so most
people were picking barcelona
and then i realized that there was a
counter to barcelona which was into
milan
because inter milan had uh zlatan
ibrahimovic
and um he just completely destroyed the
barcelona defense because
he couldn't be shaken off the ball
that's the swedish guy right yeah that's
the swedish guy
yeah yeah he in the game he was
completely [ __ ] broken so
your so then once i realized that i just
thought
i just started like just started beating
all my mates and then i was just like
you know what let's just let me let's
just limit test myself how far i can
how far can i get up with this and you
know i said top 200 earlier i'm not sure
if it's top 200 it's up to 300 but like
one of the one of the top still
impressive yeah yeah yeah it won one one
of the top few hundreds in
uh in the game at the time um and i just
kept i just kept playing until
i stopped climbing and yeah that's
that's how far i climbed and then
like i just casually told one of my one
of my mates that and he's just like have
you ever
thought about entering competitions or
stuff like that and i'm just like
no no i don't think i will because
because uh yeah i just wanted to make
anime reviews and watch anime at the
time so i just like
had no interest in playing that game in
my own in my own time takes off adidas
tracksuit
and yeah i just i just remember that now
so uh i don't know what reminds me of
that
topic that was like pre the before the
uh fifa ultimate team
nonsense yeah that was before ultimate i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
right now yeah yeah so like right now
like i think if you want to have a
legitimate competitive team in fifa
you need a team of a value of around 27
000 real money like dollars jesus that's
how much you
on average have to spend to have an
actual like top competitive team
why so all the pros have spent like
thirty thousand dollars plus
so okay [ __ ] hell okay it's just to
compete